[Music]
welcome to the reason Roundtable your
Monday afternoon News and Views podcast
from the magazine of free minds and free
markets I am Matt Welch joined by Nick
Gillespie Catherine Meng U Ward and
special guest star Emma Camp happy last
podcast of February everyone
howdy hey Matt hi there
well done so nearly a month ago the
Cochran Library described as the
international gold standard for
analyzing randomized clinical trials or
rcts which themselves are understood to
be the gold standard for medical testing
came out with a meta-analysis of 18 rcts
are you still with me studying the
effectiveness of masks in reducing the
spread of covid-19 and influenza
conclusion in the words of the lead
author Oxford's Tom Jefferson there is
just no evidence that they make any
difference full stop
full stop is British for uh gfy okay so
go look that up everyone uh rather
amazingly if not quite surprisingly the
Centers for Disease Control and
prevention reacted by saying it will not
change its recommendations that kids as
young as two wear masks in concrete
settings where infection rates are on
the rise said CDC director Rachelle
wolensky at a congressional hearing
earlier this month quote our masking
guidance doesn't really change with time
this is an important study but the
Cochran review only includes randomized
clinical trials and as you can imagine
many of the random Mai's clinical trials
were for other respiratory viruses and
infuriating quote Catherine your old
boss John Tierney and reason super
friend John Tunney had a good piece just
today in the Free Press with a second
paragraph that reads in entirety this
verdict ought to be the death knell for
mask mandates but that would require the
CDC and the rest of the public health
establishment to forsake the science and
unfortunately these leaders and their
acolytes in the media seem as determined
as ever to ignore actual science in an
Ideal mangyu World Catherine what would
the public health apparatus do now in
the wake of these findings
I think they would take advantage of uh
Emily oster's proposed covid amnesty in
which we all forgive each other for
having been both very very angry and
very very wrong in a variety of ways and
we just move on I don't think that there
actually is a really clear Way Forward
in terms of like getting to a tidy
resolution here right because the CDC is
simply never going to say
we got this completely wrong we're very
sorry and frankly even if they did and I
say this with the greatest love in my
heart possible for John Tierney who was
the best he's still not going to be
satisfied with it the people who are
angry
sort of personally viscerally angry
about how badly the mask guidance and
other guidance went
it's never going to be enough there will
never be enough apologies and so I think
that that becomes kind of beside the
point and that all we can do is do
better next time for the most part but
hold on hang on man we just got to keep
on keeping up no but we do I literally
yes even if John Tierney life is is
never going to come down heading for
another despite the use of all the
Pharmaceuticals available even though he
won't come down from his anger bear uh
place isn't it actually healthy for
institutions to self-examine and to um
make course Corrections even if it
doesn't mollify their best critics isn't
that a way to do it better next time
yeah it absolutely is but it's also just
not a realistic expectation and it's not
a priority like they should just do it
better next time because I again I I am
sympathetic in the way that I am
sympathetic to this Emily Astro proposal
like they tried they did it wrong but
they didn't do it wrong because they
were messing with us sure they did it
wrong the very very first time because
they were messing with us when they said
don't use masks because they were trying
to Noble lie us into saving masks for
the First Responders that they should be
sorry for but then they really thought
this was the right thing to do I don't
know I I remain a squish
I mean it's isn't Rochelle wolinsky
Noble lying us even to this day right
like why are we saying in any setting in
any public policy after this why is
there a mask mandate or even like yeah
I think there's a difference between get
it right going forward and like somehow
be sufficiently abased in your mistakes
in the past dick I yeah but I I've I I
don't know that they will get it right
going forward if they don't actually
kind of own the mistakes that they've
made
you know having been raised Catholic uh
I am familiar with the act of contrition
and you know this is a big deal I mean
like the CDC uh and and the entire
Public Health establishment should be
using the covet experience as a uh time
and a place to say this is what happens
when we you know get high on our own
Supply they need to put into place and I
think do it publicly uh and this is not
merely for spectacle you know this is
for getting it right the next time they
need to really do an open inquiry and
understanding of why they got it so
wrong
for so long and I do think part of that
does begin with acknowledging that they
were wrong you know and and it's you
know I don't have the anger towards
massacres or anything like that that I
you know I think John Tierney certainly
does and a lot of people do but I don't
want to be beholden to Public Health
agencies that are demonstrably wrong and
have and and refuse to explain how they
are going to do things differently the
next time but I don't want anything you
know this is something agencies you know
it doesn't like the what the problem
isn't their particular wrongness in this
particular case it's that they exist and
have these right they were wrong about
vaping they're wrong about you know
they're wrong and they're not going to
apologize for that either I I disagree
with that you know Public Health
agencies by definition are not always
wrong or they're not in the wrong and
they don't always do bad things I think
they can be better or worse they were
worse during covert than they were
during polio
um what changed what's the difference I
I mean I think that's I think that's
real really important and I think it
also goes towards establishing trust
with the public I don't even think we're
talking about rebuilding trust because
they've really you know they've
squandered whatever trust there was but
I think the CDC could do better the FDA
could do better and part of it uh you
know this is something of a of a broken
record for me but if the government
would be more forthcoming with the
limits of its knowledge and the limits
of its understanding of things openly
and talk about and engage with people in
the same way that businesses have to now
which is you know not quite on bended
knee but like government doesn't have a
reservoir of trust or confidence that it
can uh you know it can rely on they need
to be more open more transparent and
more engaging with the public Emma Nick
was talking about anger John Tierney's
anger which is a never-ending let's be
honest but you're a recent college
student you've been wearing a mask for
like 15 of your life or probably more I
don't even know but do you have anger
from this and can you testify it just a
bit like what are the practical
realities what was it like uh to be in
that situation when you were being
masked I remember when I was in the
recent uh DC office most recently I was
sitting around all you children uh for a
while and I brought up the subject of
masking college and everyone's eyes went
nuts can you uh talk about what does
that mean did they start spinning or
it's just just nuts little flames
shooting out of them can you talk about
how you feel about all this uh you know
now that the Cochrane studies come out
and basically said yeah it wasn't all
worth it yeah I I certainly have some
anger but I I think I'm sympathetic to
Catherine's position which is that while
it would be nice to have an apology
you're just not gonna get one
um and I also I was gonna bring up the
Emily Oster article um because I think
that when we have all of these problems
post covered restrictions especially
relating to college students and school
age people right where you have kids
that are more depressed than ever and
they can't read and we have all of these
you know 20 years of improvement in test
scores that we've lost I I really think
we're better off using our political
will to improve those outcomes and to
attack the problems that we have right
now rather than trying to exact
Vengeance even though it would be really
awesome to get some vengeance
but when I think about the period of my
life in which I was under like really
strict covid restrictions which was
really my junior year of college and
then sort of partially in my senior year
of college
um it's honestly kind of
surreal I remember at the time I was
reflecting on this I was actually quite
not so much my senior year really not at
all basically post getting a vaccine
covid was over for me but before that I
was sort I was really into it almost
like I was the person that was like Hey
everybody can we wear a mask I was like
why was I like a weird little mask Nazi
and when I was thinking about it the
reason why wasn't that I was actually
afraid of getting covered it was that I
was afraid of what would happen to me
and what the university would do to me
if I got coven because I had a bunch of
Roommates the pot of people I was in had
a bunch of Roommates so if I tested for
coven me and about 15 other people would
have to test for covid and we'd have to
be completely isolated for two weeks
maybe whisked off to quarantine dorms
and you know there was a huge social
cost to getting covered right if you got
coveted you were a playgrad right and
then it's also all of the social cost
and what I was afraid of and what made
me sort of shiver in the cold at 2AM
quote unquote six feet apart from my
friends instead of just having a party
like a normal person is I was afraid of
what my college would do to me not
afraid of what covid would do to me and
it really was the level of insanity at
certain points is
um I don't know it's infuriating but
also
almost amusing to look back on I I mean
for one we had basically a mask mandate
until the end of my senior year and so
you know you could go to frat parties
with 200 people and that was fine but
you had to wear a mask to sit you know
six feet away from someone else in class
but my College's chapter of the ydsa
um did some particularly interesting
the young Democratic socialists of
America they were the source of a lot of
Fury over UVA not doing enough when they
were doing quite a lot I think my
favorite was there were a couple
in-person classes at the beginning of
the Fall 2020 semester and these classes
were like 15 people and sharing an
entire Auditorium like they were very
distanced and to protest this the ydsa
staged a die-in which was you guessed it
in person and involved college students
laying down in front of the Rotunda UVA
a very very uniformly six feet apart to
show how many UVA students were gonna
die because of in-person classes anyone
know how many Eva students died of coven
none there was a Tracker I also believe
none were hospitalized uh it's almost
like covet is not really a huge risk to
healthy 18 to 22 year olds oh yeah we're
still like at a thousand deaths right uh
under 18 from yeah that's yeah that's
not much at all you just you just get it
about the uh die-ins and the protests
with coffins uh held by uh teachers in
the New York City public school system
Nick go forth y'all are classier than us
because we just had uh that people were
just wrapped in trash bag like they just
want body bags here in DC so it's nice
that you had real coffins honestly it's
collapsible that's good but you know the
choice isn't between you know absolute
foam flecked spittle rage Vengeance and
doing nothing it's having an open
process of like the CDC explaining why
they did what they did understanding you
know and again this isn't about like
punishing people as much as it is like
figuring out what were the processes in
place that got it so wrong at so many
levels for the CDC and we've done things
like this you know with uh you know the
Rockefeller commission and the church
Committee in you know in the 70s for
internal spying it doesn't work forever
but there are punctuated moments where
the government has said you know what we
really screwed up and we're going to
examine our process we're going to do it
in the light of day and we're going to
work through those steps and again the
two-fold uh you know outcome of benefit
of that is one is that you hopefully get
a better process because things can be
better or worse and then the other the
secondary effect is that you might
actually help build public confidence
not in the anger Bears of the world
you're not in the cocaine anger Bears of
the world but in the vast majority of
people who are willing to go along you
know and say like okay government can be
better can I put cocaine anger bear as
our next is it is it our next cover or
do we do the cocaine anger bear as our
next centerfold do you think uh
certainly uh uh uh Halloween uh our
quarterly Halloween party uh should in I
think the next issue should include that
you know some cocaine in it as well to
uh to Nick's point I just want to add
two words Richard everleven Feynman
okay that was a good good I was really I
thought you were going with Richard
Nixon yeah
um uh Catherine uh R Jacob solum
an American hero uh has been writing
about uh the cdc's and Michelle wolinski
in particular is very shoddy use of mask
science over the years he did this
before the Cochrane study and then when
the Cockroach study came out he reminded
people again the gap between their
conclusions and what and how the CDC and
wolinsky have been using these um facts
and for which reason and Jacob were
slapped with a potentially misleading
label on Facebook do you want to talk
about Facebook dissing the high quality
and super careful work of Jacob
everleving Solomon yeah I'm pretty mad
about it because
um how dare they how dare they come for
my Jacob solemn who is
he's so precise he's so careful he does
not over claim like there's the very
idea that the same people who shoveled
around
misinformation disinformation whatever
you want to call it about so many
aspects of covid and masking and the lab
leak Theory and 20 other things should
then put that a Jacob solemn column
is quote missing context quote could
mislead people and that independent fact
Checkers did not enjoy it how dare they
they are blessed to read every word the
Jake of solemn offers to them and you
know the fact that these labels are
getting put on pieces that are
specifically teaching the controversy
right pieces that are explaining the two
sides and you know coming to a
conclusion certainly but not without
evidence is just frankly infuriating
this is of course part and parcel with
uh our recent troubles with the global
disinformation index which found that
reason was one of the 10 riskiest sites
for online news despite not at any point
anywhere in that study finding a single
thing that was actually wrong
not one that's not the methodology of
the study it was not to look and see
if things were wrong which is where I
would start if I was trying to figure
that question out but Jacob has rightly
written that like the entire concept of
disinformation at this point is just so
corrupted right it is it is simply a
sort of accusation that you fling at
people whose conclusions you don't enjoy
um or whose motivations you suspect or
both and you know I do think that it
will probably
lose its power over time but not before
the concept has done quite a lot of harm
um and I think the these Facebook labels
are a good example of that Nick there's
a we've talked a reason written or
Reason including Jacob Solomon a
memorable cover story from like 15 years
ago about the totalitarian implications
of Public Health but we talked about
that is there a sense of the sort of the
paternalism right anti uh daddy-state
mommy State uh paternalism of government
and public health agencies do you see
that ethic creeping over into journalism
does it seem that there's more like
leading you it's like as if explanatory
journalism isn't explaining uh what a
thing is or a fact is it's explaining
how you should think about it and feel
about it and maybe act yeah I mean I
think you've uh really uh hit the nail
on the head there Matt that you know
there's an encroaching sense of where
we're not going to actually show both
sides of anything and let you come to
your own conclusion and in more and more
areas of life that public discourse is
about instructing people in proper
thinking not as a you know not as a
process but as a conclusion
um and that's a real loss I think a lot
about this because I there was a moment
when I was in grad school in the late
80s early 90s where there became this
palpable switch from where older
professors and God helped me that I'm
going to say anything good about the
baby boom but the people the professors
who would bore all of the students with
you know discussions of being tear
gassed on the UC campuses in the late
60s et cetera they were like hey you
know what the point of the university is
to have a place that's apart from the
rest of society where you can just run
with whatever ideas you have and see
where they lead good bad or indifferent
and they were being elbowed out by
people who were like no the what we are
doing is we are training a kind of Cadre
of salesmen who are going out and
selling a particular product which was
you know for them it was a kind of uh
pathetic pre-end of Communism uh
critique of capitalism but that that was
like all the difference in the world
like the idea of let's talk about it to
we are past the point of talking you are
going out and selling this and I feel
like that has crept into more and more
things and I hadn't really thought about
it in the context of explaining you know
or explain our service journalism for
thinking but that's where we're at man
uh that's a good Bridge into our next
topic which because Peter is not here
and not moderating was not going to have
a label
um but I appreciate uh uh I know I'm
against the labels when we have them but
I miss them when they're gone that's
contrarianism at its best I guess that's
fine yeah
um uh last week in a um the Miss can we
call this section The Missing Link nope
Emma Camp uh wrote about this last week
in a telegraphed move Florida
legislators who were loyal to Governor
Ron DeSantis meatball Ron DeSantis
introduced a bill that would remove many
of the legal protections against
defamation lawsuits that had been
established by the 1964 Supreme Court
case New York Times versus Sullivan
which imposed an actual malice standard
for aggrieved parties to prove their
critics in the press or elsewhere had
defamed them Emma you wrote about this
bill including its critics within the
free speech and Biz can you walk us
through what this would do and why
people are leery of it yes I definitely
can do that as you all can tell the good
people at home can't see it but I
lots of notes because this bill is uh
calorie dense I think is how I would
describe it I think any one of its
Provisions would be worth talking about
but uh I guess DeSantis and his allies
decided to save us the trouble and put
about seven Provisions that are worth
talking about in there at once
um so the way I think about what this
bill is trying to do it's it's kind of
can be broken down into two main
categories one category is going after
journalists using Anonymous sources and
the second is kind of changing the way
actual malice can be required to get a
victory in a defamation case
um so when it comes to the anonymous
sources Provisions one of the first
things that the bill does is that it
creates a carve out in Florida's
journalist privilege law which is kind
of all that a lot of kind of federal
circuits and states have which basically
means that under most circumstances
journalists will not be required to
reveal uh to identify their Anonymous
sources in legal proceedings this bill
would just create a carve out to that
law when it relates to defamation cases
the second thing that this would do in
relating to journalists that's uh
probably one of the more noteworthy
Provisions is that it would just
automatically assume uh for defamation
purposes that any statement by an
anonymous source is false the law would
just assume that they're false and then
kind of making things worse if a
journalist refuses to identify their
anonymous source in order to obtain a
victory in a defamation case all the
plaintiff has to do is prove negligence
so basically actual malice wouldn't be
required
um which kind of dovetails nicely into
the changes to actual malice
um so actual malice under this bill will
be able to be inferred in a in a
significantly broader number of
circumstances than current defamation
law allows So currently actual malice is
basically defined as uh assuming that's
made with knowledge that it was false or
with Reckless disregard of whether it
was false or not this bill basically
does away with that
um and so for example uh you can infer
actual malice if the statement was
fabricated by the defendant
inherently implausible based again kind
of going back based on an unverified
anonymous report or under this other
category of having obvious reasons to
doubt the notable thing about that is
one of the um one of the kinds of
statements that means that there is an
an obvious reason to doubt its ferocity
is uh if someone makes an accusation
that somebody else discriminated on the
basis of race sex sexual orientation or
gender identity because Ron DeSantis can
never stay too far away from the culture
War basically statements that accuse
someone of discrimination on the basis
of these protected characteristics uh
both will be kind of into themselves
reasons to and for actual malice and
that category is defamation per se which
basically means if the accusation is
false it is defamation and of course the
law also sort of removes some of the
ways in which someone might try to prove
that their accusation Isn't false
um when it comes to accusations of
discrimination on the basis of sexual
orientation and gender identity you
can't appeal to someone's religious
beliefs or their quote scientific
beliefs another provision related to
actual malice is that when the
accusation at hand when the allegedly
defamatory statement doesn't relate to
the reason why the person is a public
figure
um you don't need to show actual malice
um so my understanding of that would be
something like if someone is a
professional basketball player and the
allegedly defamatory statement is that
they like cheated on their wife or
something you wouldn't need to prove
actual malice but if it's an accusation
that they took performance-enhancing
drugs or something you would
um and then there's also with their wife
also with their wife preferably um yeah
that's how I like to take a performance
enhancing drugs okay I have a little I
will leave it there because it's
obviously very very long but thank you
for that uh thorough debriefing and you
can Circle back to other bits um if we
have time for but Catherine I wanted to
get you in here because uh you know Ron
D sanctimonious isn't the only one who's
going after New York Times versus
Sullivan
um you know uh the before we had butt
Gorsuch we had but Thomas among uh
libertarian people looking for any kind
of Salve uh to console them with uh
Republican presidencies but it's
Clarence Thomas and a little bit Neil
Gorsuch uh who seemed kind of eager to
revisit this uh what gives dang it
I honestly don't understand I mean I get
that we are just in a situation now
where because all sides have resorted to
kind of power power politics to
um you know to like as Stephanie Slade
calls it kind of Will To Power
conservatism versus a kind of
authoritarian progressivism
um so that means that we're just we're
just looking for cudgels anything that's
kind of laying on the ground that we can
hit each other with we want to weaponize
it and um it's you know it's just hard
for me to understand why people would
look at for instance the UK where these
rules are already quite different than
our own and where speech is you know
constantly being restrained and stifled
and say like yeah let's make our system
look more like that like that's that's
where we want to go
um it it's just it doesn't it doesn't
make sense to me except if you just
assume that everyone is taking a kind of
nihilistic we want these weapons in our
hands and we don't we're not worried
about the fact that soon enough the
other side will wield them as well
um I think that Emma had it right when
she said DeSantis never misses an
opportunity to culture War
so most of this is about that
um if desantis's record on culture War
um kind of big big pushes big efforts is
any indication this isn't gonna happen
like this won't end up really being a
thing uh our cover story of the current
issue is a great essay by Eric Bane that
makes this point
um that DeSantis keeps doing big splashy
culture warish things but they keep not
really fully manifesting and that is our
only saving grace with him at this point
um I don't want to rely on that
obviously
um you know if you if he tries hard
enough enough times one of these things
is going to go through but
um I am it is my profound hope that this
will fail as his previous efforts have
failed kind of reminds me uh when you
put it that way of um of what I wrote
about Hillary Clinton before the 2016
election looking through her history of
coming up with uh proposals laws task
forces uh at all having to do with
restricting access to video games or
Internet uh to kids to protect the
children and one after another were
struck down by the Supreme Court usually
or by other courts in the system and
that was the protection then but Nick I
wonder if um both of us uh have in the
past cited the I think 2009 book by uh
the NYU Law Prof Barry Friedman called
the will of the people how public
opinion has influenced the Supreme Court
and shaped the meaning of the
Constitution
um where to boil it down over much
um he basically says Supreme Court kind
of ratifies where public consensus has
shifted after the fact do you worry
um that he's more right than uh the
let's say or like that factor that he's
talking about is going to have more sway
than what we have also seen in the last
10 years which is a pretty robust
defense of the First Amendment at the
Supreme Court level
yeah I mean the Supreme Court has been
great on Free Speech uh really for like
25 years 30 years or you could take it
all the way back to Sullivan uh you know
one of the things that I think about
kind of going into Old Man mode again is
to you know if you grew up in the 70s
and 80s you took Free Speech as an
absolute right or as close to an
absolute right as it could be you know
as just the universal truth
um there nobody was arguing anymore it
was it was a self-evident truth and
increasingly you know it's becoming
clear that that period from you know
about 1955 until maybe 2005 or something
there was there was a good 50 years
where that was true and it's just it
wasn't true before that and increasingly
it seems to be less and less taken it's
certainly not taken for granted and I do
think that the Supreme Court uh you know
follows where the American population is
or republican census it is which is
deeply troubling this push to open up
the libel laws really does come from the
right and it needs you know this was a
big thing that Donald Trump started
talking about wanting to open up the
libel laws uh meatball Ron I really
think cocaine Ron sounds really good and
he is from Florida and cocaine is pretty
good as a you know modifier for any any
political figure
um but you know DeSantis this is also
should be seen as an attempt to steal
some of Trump's Thunder while also
shutting the door on uh you know the
orange Mussolini or whatever people
ended up calling him
um but it's it's deeply disturbing and
you know conservatives and I you know uh
conservatives have no moral compass at
this point as a political block they
feel like they are so under attack they
are willing to do whatever they can to
kind of stay in the conversation or or
take it over and it's not going to be
good it's really really deeply deeply
disturbing and the unfortunately you
know people on the left I don't think
they're going after libel laws as much
but they are you know they are waiting
at the table to say yeah let's regulate
speech more we've been pushing this in a
different way for decades I'm so glad to
have you here this it's it's really not
good and I worry about the Supreme Court
on all of this I'm a a reason and
Libertarians in general have been among
the first to point out
um the uh kind of injustices that have
happened in the name of abused uh due
process uh whether in in actual uh
writing of due process in the law or
kind of the cultural sense of due
process I'm thinking here about
um uh under Obama the uh changing of the
Title IX rules to go after campus sexual
assault which really uh lowered the bar
for being able to kind of kick a kid out
without having him usually him uh able
to defend him self and I think about Joe
Biden is bringing those things back
thinking also about the excesses of me
too people who were kind of drummed out
of polite Society even though there
really wasn't a lot of evidentiary
standard and some of the stuff that came
after George Floyd in the summer of 2020
kind of a racial Reckoning uh type of
overreaction so we're you know we tend
to say hey look you're going too far on
this
um people are are innocent until proven
guilty I wonder if in defense of the
conservatives that nicolespie just
slimed
um is there something that Libertarians
should think about in terms of a remedy
for people who find themselves on the
butt end of this I mean the at the uh
DeSantis had a media panel a couple of
weeks ago that was uh you know we were
sitting at a desk with the word truth
behind him it's kind of strange one of
the people he had there was the
Covington kid right the kid who was
defamed
um and that's a teaser for something
that I'm going to bring up a little bit
later
um uh not to famed but I'm sorry wrong
word but uh he was slimed uh by the
media everywhere is being a racist
because the way he smirked uh on Capitol
Hill in 2019
um should we be thinking more
proactively about hey look there's there
should be a higher penalty Associated or
a cost incurred by super casual Reckless
allegations
um that are not just like on social
media but they're by journalistic
institutions
I think in the social sphere yes but I
am extremely cautious about getting the
law involved
um you know and I'll be the first to say
there are definitely downsides to the
current defamation law we have you know
I'm sure all of us have had people say
nasty and untrue things about us I
certainly have had a lot of experience
of people a lot of them at once saying a
lot of nasty and untrue things about me
and it's not fun there are downsides but
there are also Matt has apologized I did
he won't do it again
um but you know they're also uh I in my
opinion uh way more upsides to having
the law that we currently have like yes
it can really damage people's lives like
the Covington kid is a good example when
they have these things said about them
um but it can also damage people's lives
to be in a world where you say something
that maybe is untrue maybe isn't maybe
it's just me and maybe it's a mistake
and then all of a sudden you have
um a massive legal battle on your hands
something that I forgot to mention
earlier that I think is really important
is that when it comes to that accusation
that someone discriminated on the basis
of these protected characteristics
um if you are found to have committed
defamation along with all the other deaf
all the other damages the court is
supposed to give you you also have
another thirty five thousand dollar fine
um which is absurd right and so I think
we can both say like yes when
journalistic institutions publish things
that are false or like nasty in a
particularly
likely to be false way even if they're
technically opinion there should be a
strong social cost that people should
feel comfortable saying that this is
wrong
um and you know you should retract the
article you should apologize but I think
when we get the law involved
um we run a really high chance of
silencing more speech than the the the
the costs just outweigh the benefits in
my opinion just I wanted to sort of note
an example of this mentality already
permeating the conversation which is the
New York Times uh the letter about
coverage of transgender issues that was
signed by 890 contributors uh last week
two weeks ago whenever it was
um there's a sentence in that letter and
they say the natural destination of poor
editorial judgment is the court of law
that's the scariest [__] I've ever heard
and not just because I'm the one out
here exercising poor editorial judgment
every day by publishing this podcast but
also
like that whole framework is wrong the
natural destination of poor editorial
judgment is getting out competed in the
media Space by another publication the
natural destination of poor editorial
judgment is having to publish an op-ed
on the other side or a bunch of letters
to the editor it is absolutely not a
court of law we have all these other
mechanisms to deal with dumb opinions
and and even lies
but we should not use the courts for
that that's the wrong way to go about it
and the fact that these you know
hundreds of journalists were threatening
a publication in which they have
appeared they were thinkers they called
themselves thinkers by the way they were
all there their words had appeared in
the times right like or their their work
had appeared in the times and um the
fact that they were none too subtly
threatening legal action for just like
having the wrong angle on trans stuff
sometimes shows that um you know the
thing that that you were raising earlier
about you know the concern that the
court will simply follow and I think by
public opinion we also typically mean
Elite opinion there which are two
different things
um yeah that that bodes ill indeed uh
Catherine uh to to close this section I
wanted to make sure to give you at least
a few seconds to reflect on uh your High
witch Priestess JK Rowling
um out there uh threatening litigation
right and left uh against her critics
who are quite frequently if not even
typically deranged in calling your
transpho and what else uh whatever else
and those critics because they're in the
United Kingdom uh which is a second
world country
um uh are like being brought to heal
um is that a good thing
nope that's exactly what I was saying
like the UK is not our model here we do
not want our country to look like that
and um I think you know not only is it a
bad thing in terms of the specifics of
these cases
um I think it's a bad thing
for her position
right like if you
if you want to stick up for her
if you know which I sometimes do I mean
I I don't exactly share her take on
trans issues but I don't think it's
insane I don't think it's literally
causing trans people to die for her to
have the opinions that she has and she's
making it hard for me to defend her I
sure wish she wouldn't do that I wish
she would just calmly State her view in
the public sphere which is what she's
historically done pretty well
um you know I personally wouldn't have
again done it the way that she did it by
just kind of occasionally popping up and
doing a tweet that absolutely incenses a
really really highly invested and angry
group of people it's not it's not how I
like to do argumentation but that's fine
if that's her approach what is not fine
is suing people to shut them up all
right we're going to get to our listener
email of the week here in a moment but
first a reminder that this episode is
sponsored by betterhelp friends
do you really know yourself
are you the same person that you were
five years ago 10 years ago
54 and a half years ago and if not are
you adjusting your self-conception and
way of operating in the world
accordingly therapy with a trained
independent Arbiter can be a worthwhile
way of deepening your self-awareness
tinkering with your interior operating
system and coping better with the world
did I say better yes I did here's where
better help online therapy comes in
better help is easy to use super
flexible entirely online just fill out a
quick questionnaire and start increasing
your self-knowledge right away you can
discover your potential with better help
just visit betterhelp.com Roundtable
today to get 10 off your first month
that's better help
help.com slash Roundtable go there today
you'll be glad you did all right a
reminder email us your readably short
queries to Roundtable at reason.com this
one comes from our unfailingly polite
International correspondent Nicholas
dorf and it goes a little something like
this beloved reason editors this is like
the song a letter from Saint Paul uh I'd
like to ask you a kind of a meta
question something about reason magazine
itself if you had to choose only about
three printed numbers asterisk Madness
putting in there of the magazine to have
and to read for the rest of your lives
which editions would you choose and why
which number or maybe article I love the
word number there do you think better
represents the essence of free minds and
free markets in the same sense which
particular article would you suggest for
an average person to read and to
convince him or her to just to subscribe
sorry love and peace I'm going to edit
this moderators privilege uh everyone
gets to name one issue of the magazine
and one particular article to satisfy
these particular requirements Catherine
you start
I would love to start I'm gonna name the
October 2018 issue this was our first
debate issue uh and I loved it because I
as per our entire previous first half of
this podcast I think that people should
be able to talk about stuff uh
controversial stuff stuff that they
disagree about they should be able to do
it in a way that is productive and I
think that the way that people are
productive is when you give them overly
formal guidelines and boundaries in
which to do things this is who I am as a
person but it's also how debate works
and I think it's good
um that issue was fun and spicy we
talked about Nick and I debated
anarchism uh and I won and we also
debated taxation as theft is are still
the three saddest words in this activism
we talked about abortion we talked about
data privacy gay wedding cakes
vegetarianism and more
um we're doing it again we're doing
another debate issue the next issue will
be a debate issue and
um you know the idea of both of these
issues is not just let's fight about
everything like with the socialists it's
let's fight about stuff Libertarians
disagree about and I think that that is
a really good place to start you know
share some common values share something
um you know some basic terms of
agreement but then there's still lots of
a lot to fight about I think it's reason
that it's best when we can make space
for those type of conversations so get
ready for debate issue two Electric
Boogaloo uh article
I am gonna pick the cover story of what
I think is actually the best issue of
Reason ever uh which is uh the one
published in June 2004 under Nick's
editorship the we know where you live
issue which had uh little GPS pictures
of everybody's house on the cover which
in 2004 was a real
mind-blowing moment
um the often underappreciated cover
story of that issue by Declan McCullough
was about how it's fine that privacy is
over and I when I read that piece it
really changed my mind
um which is always a sign of a good
article when you went and think in one
thing it came out The Far Side thinking
the other thing the piece was about the
upsides of zero privacy and I have
looked at many of the debates including
the current debate about Ai and
surveillance associated with AIS through
that lens I think it's prevented me from
giving way to the Doom and Gloom that so
many of my fellow Libertarians have
fallen to
Nick you were an editor of this fine
magazine what are your picks or uh best
uh or you know most noteworthy and for
whatever reason uh issue of the mag and
best article
so uh the writer had asked which was you
know a good issue and story that would
get people to subscribe and I'm picking
the 2019 August September issue as my
favorite issue and that was one where
the glass was half full and half empty
depending if you were on the front or
the back of the cover and
um kind of similar to the debate issue
uh this one also under Catherine's
guidance but there were so many stories
even the negative stories were kind of
positive
um and I think it it's an incredible
sampler it's like you know the Whitman
sampler of Reason magazine takes on why
things are getting better and while why
there are still problems but we're going
to overcome them it's a really um you
know it just exudes the kind of studied
optimism I would say that Libertarians
have their best kind of you know show
the world and I think reason has
consistently from its very early days so
I really like to 2019 August September
issue because it shows how much how far
we've come you know since 1968 say when
the magazine started and how much
further we're going to be going for my
the particular story I am a huge fan of
Chuck freund's Charles Paul freins sorry
from the March 2002 issue which is
called In Praise of vulgarity and it was
in the wake of 9 11 and the invasion of
Afghanistan
um it
um it talked about what happened in
Afghanistan in particular when the
Taliban was deposed and the men went out
and got their beard shaved and their
hair cut in an outlawed you know the
Taliban among many crazy things had
outlawed Beetle haircuts and what was
called the Titanic which was the quaff
that Leonardo DiCaprio had in Titanic
and it was very popular in Afghanistan
in the Taliban you know ban that for men
they ban nail salons and all kind kinds
of Cosmetics for women so the men went
out shaved their beards got their hair
cut and women went to nail salons and
out of that Chuck built this incredible
story of why people are subversive of
state and corporate power in a way that
is just amazingly learned wide-ranging
and fascinating and that story in and of
itself I think exemplifies what reason
does best which is bring a radically
distinct Viewpoint one that is
optimistic but is also realistic and is
very
um you know is very clear in the limits
of the world view but also the power of
it and he took on a bunch of critics
from within the United States who were
saying things like you know it was
pathetic that Afghans given Freedom went
and did things they enjoyed rather than
things that they should you know like
they need to eat their cultural
vegetables and go to Serious movies or
Symphonies or this or that
impressive vulgarities just it's a
Timeless story despite the fact or maybe
because it is in absolute conversation
with one of the hinge points of the past
half decade uh half second I will uh
second that uh nomination Emma Camp
these all happened before you were born
of course uh but uh what's your uh go-to
issue and article in response to this
question
yeah I was thinking about this and
because I have only been working at
reason for about eight or nine months or
so I feel like I don't quite have the
fount of knowledge on print issues so I
think choosing the one since I've been
here that I enjoyed reading the most I
think my favorite issue and my favorite
article are in the same issue which is
the I believe it's the October 2022
authoritarian convergence
issue
um I think that cover Story by Stephanie
Slade
presents such a compelling argument for
why kind of a liberty minded view on
politics is so important because it
profiles The Descent into
authoritarianism both in terms of trying
to squ you know quash civil liberties
but also regulate the market on both the
left and right even if they're doing it
in slightly different ways and sort of
the importance of preserving the same
third option there
um and of course and speaking of third
options and that issue there's also sort
of a history of the libertarian party
um probably the most famous third option
in American politics
um and I just found it to be a really
solid issue it had also my first piece
in reason magazine itself just a little
topic but you know it it has a warm
place in my heart because
uh the ones I'll take uh July 2011 this
is under my editorship but I claim no
credit for it uh aside from giving to
then editors uh Jacob selm the
aforementioned American hero and Radley
Balco in one of his last acts uh for a
reason before he moved on uh then to the
Huffington Post
um I told them give us a criminal
justice special issue
um and uh I will just sit back and take
all the credit for it um it was longest
issue by far uh during my editorship and
and it probably is competitive with one
of the longest we've ever done and it
was just a a wonderful thorough going
compilation of the very kind of robust
and internally you know a quarreling uh
group of people who want to figure out
ways to uh fix the criminal justice
system in the United States you have
Radley Balco in there Ken white of popat
Fame Peter moscows Michelle Alexander
Mark kleiman Harvey silverglade Tim
Lynch just and even the margins uh then
the marginalia in in the issue are
terrific there's it's more about the uh
some of its parts than any particular
Edition and I have fondness for it
particularly because
as I said it was uh one of Radley
palko's last uh efforts for the magazine
Radley did a wonderful job in
prioritizing criminal justice issue for
reason and also like kind of creating or
helping to create a new category of
young Libertarians people got into
libertarianism because of what they saw
as the way uh the criminal justice
system was mistreating people and
causing Injustice and at the time of him
leaving there was some worry in some
quarters that oh you know somehow that's
going to be the end of Reason talking
about criminal justice issues in this
way not only does the issue kind of
refute that but so does all of our track
record ever since including a special
October 2020 issue called fix the police
we'll rebuild on on that that came in so
uh very terrific and I and I just
appreciate
um you know stuff stuff that happens on
my watch that I don't touch um it's the
goal of all management as Nick knows um
individual article that strikes me as
particularly noteworthy about a style of
thing that reason uh does and
differentiates itself in the modern
media landscape has kind of teased
before this came in January uh 20th of
2019 by Robbie Suave uh title on it is
the media wildly mischaracterized that
video of Covington Catholic students
confronting a Native American Veteran
what is amazing about this piece is that
Robbie did nothing
that any other journalist couldn't do
this is I think like a day and a half or
so after the initial outrage which
became wall-to-wall news for reasons
that just seemed absurd thinking back on
it a smirk on a kid's face uh meant
racism or something
um but Robbie went and watched all the
source video because there was a lot of
video floating around that people posted
on YouTube in various places and
discovered that the media narratives not
just like you know people uh talking on
Twitter but like stuff in the Washington
Post and elsewhere were just wildly
wrong and easily disprovably wrong
um and so using actual patience and
looking through available evidence to
discover that media narratives become
self-reinforcing Loops of wrong
information
is one of the Specialties that I think
reason uh does many many such examples
over the years uh going back to our uh
classic Love Canal story
um and and others uh but this is that's
the thing that we do and it's a way to
pull in people who don't aren't familiar
with reason and don't necessarily care
or know about where we lean
philosophically or editorially I think
people appreciate honest Brokers out
there in the news and that's the memo
all right we're getting late here in
this uh robust episode so let's go to
what we have all been consuming in the
cultural Arena Catherine why don't you
go first
I had some beer yeah
um and since suderman's not here I will
uh pick up the slack on booze based
consumption I guess
um I had uh I purchased this beer
obviously exclusively for the name which
is uh it was it's a it's a third party
triple so it's uh by Denison's Brewing
Company it's got a cute little I don't
know it's like a fox or something in a
party hat with a Blazer on on the label
and um it is a it is a Belgian
style uh
9.4 my friends and so that's what I want
to say is basically that is the only
appropriate
strength for a third party celebrating
beer you're really gonna need to drink
to get through it if that's how you
affiliate
um it uh it is characterized by I am
told in the tasty notes the fact that
belgians use additional candied sugar
as part of their fermentable sugars
which makes things fruity and spicy and
very very boozy uh if there's one thing
I can say about third parties it's their
fruity spicy and very very boozy and
this was a good beer so my
recommendation to you
in suderman's absence nick uh what have
you been consuming
uh I finally got around to reading the
philosophy of modern song by Bob Dylan
which came out late last year and uh it
is uh and I also want to point out the
um uh the Spotify playlist uh that so
because it's it's a series of songs it's
you know 60 songs or something like that
66 songs that Dylan kind of does notes
on and then there's a guy uh by the name
of TJ McDonald who put the playlist
together on Spotify which is also just
uh it you know an incredible Revelation
to listen to the songs but Dylan goes
through the American Songbook of about
like a hundred the past hundred years or
so and it's just very wide-ranging uh
his section on Little Richard and Tutti
Frutti is great and I just want to read
a little bit from it uh Little Richard
is the master of the double entender
Tutti Frutti is a good example a fruit a
male homosexual and Tutti Frutti is all
fruit it's also a sugary ice cream a gal
named Sue and a gal named Daisy and
they're both transvestites of all the
people who sang Tutti Frutti Dylan
writes Pat Boone was probably the only
one who knew what he was singing about
and Pat knows about speaking in tongues
as well it is just CR in in it in the
particulars it's cryptic in the best way
that Dylan is but more important Dylan
has been kind of locking down uh you
know a broad understanding of American
culture for the past Century at least so
you know and
um in a world where people keep talking
about how you know
um including Dylan how International
Capital has kind of destroyed all uh
traditions and customs and the the the
Primacy of local of you know of small
things and and kind of places that are
shut off from the rest of the world
Dylan is piecing together a way to live
in this world and to kind of keep your
bearing and to keep open to the vast
possibilities that have been opened up
by this destruction of the local and of
the small and uh the philosophy of
modern song is just an incredible read
it's wonderful you can dip in and out of
it uh it's it's like a pint of ice cream
that never disappears but you know every
night you can have a couple of spoonfuls
fantastic and then I highly highly
recommend the Spotify playlist the
version of trucking and Dylan's tastes
are extremely eclectic in this uh at one
point he's talking about Bill Monroe and
Roddy James Dio in the same sentence the
guy who invented you know is the modern
father of Bluegrass and Ronnie James Dio
who is one of the great uh kind of
satanic Rock Masters but the playlist
there's a version of trucking uh from
the Grateful Dead's 1972 album the one
where the ice the kid is hitting himself
on the head with the ice cream cone that
is fantastic and if you're reading it to
Dylan's kind of summary of trucking it's
it's Transcendent so the the philosophy
of modern song I Would supplement that
with go check out an interview I think
it was done in the Wall Street Journal
but there's a longer version on Bob
Dylan's own site Bob Dylan notes I think
it is Nick um maybe you know better than
I that came out when the book came out
and it's like many Bob Dylan interviews
and as Jack Shaffer has said before many
times uh Bob Dylan still undefeated in
all interviews but uh but it's just it's
marvelous it it's uh to Nick's point
about a way of being in the world a way
of consuming music a way being open to
things in the world it's just a it's a
beautiful thing to behold so go and to
remember things in an age where stuff
disappears before we you know every news
cycle we have forgotten what we're
outraged about we only remember the
feeling of being angry
uh Dylan gives us a place the hanger I'm
still mad at the balloon
when are we gonna kill another balloon
uh Emma Camp what have you consumed in
the cultural Arena over the past week or
so I have sort of
sped through the podcast from American
public media called sold a story which
is about how it came to be that about
two and three American fourth graders
can't really read and the various forces
at play the various kind of
scientifically debunked curriculum that
are in many cases still in use that led
to a circumstance where we are not
teaching children to read using phonics
which based on the science we have is
basically the only way that people learn
how to read and it really gripped me as
someone who writes a lot about education
and kind of Education data for reason it
really kind of exercised me and sort of
haunted me after I had listened to it
because of how angry it made me and
because of how many young lives were
likely could have permanently destroyed
because of ineffective teaching
very good I will add for my
um uh entrance here I've always been a
fan of weird little museums uh I'm a fan
of bizarre you're a weird little Museum
a [__] I don't know what that means you
should see actually holy cow but I
cannot just describe my office this is a
very weird little Museum uh should I
show you the mat doll for the Matt Welch
to see the map doll this is we can't
well it's an awesome audio podcast dumb
butt yes like what are we you're looking
at a bat though there we are um anyways
uh that's all we're talking about sure
that's not a repurposed Ben Affleck
though it's not he never had long orange
hair
um
yeah I went to a uh a House museum in
Los Angeles in the silver lake
neighborhood it used to be called
Edendale for trivia Buffs back home
called The Holy Land exhibition and holy
cow is it just so weird I'm really glad
in retrospect that last time our
wonderful art director Joanne Andreas
and went to LA she's like what should I
do in L.A Matt you used to live there
and knowing how weird Joanna is she's
got like stuffed squirrels in her wall
in her apartment here um like go to the
Holy Land exhibition even though I
myself hadn't been there
um now I have took my daughter it's
amazing so it is a uh this guy named
Antonia futterer
um just are already weird that a guy has
an Antonia uh name uh he uh 100 years
ago traveled extensively to the Middle
East to the Holy Land in the 1920s
um because he was in search of the Ark
of the Covenant yes this is the person
who's likely the semi model for the
Indiana Jones character although he was
not a uh prominent archaeologist of any
type he was a uh as they say eclectic
religious adventurer
so he went out there to try to like get
stuff uh from Syria Damascus and Egypt
and Israel and uh and he looked admit
for a long time for the uh for the ark
and he would bring back things to his
silver lake house
um little trinkets tourist things and
big wonderful kind of discoveries and
Lord knows how he uh acquired all of
them they're a little bit light on those
details uh it's as a buy appointment
only Museum there's a family that runs
the place I don't know what relation
that family has with the Federer estate
maybe they are the federal state nothing
is made clear
um you just walk in and this great
extravagant kind of uh uh uh elderly
magisterial hippie gal comes out fumbles
with a gigantic set of keys trying to
figure out how to get to the Damascus
room and then walks you up a set of
stairs and you're in this room and see
this incredible inlaid 200 year old
Gaming table that has all these
different nooks and crannies it's just
crazy it is set up as an Interfaith
understanding place so there's the juice
stuff the Muslim stuff and the Christian
stuff
um there is a piece of the Temple mount
a tile because there's an earthquake
there when he was around and apparently
he's just like hmm like pick the potato
and Earth a likely earthquake put it in
a shirt or something I don't know they
dress you up in a costume at some point
for reasons that are unexplained she has
this whole like you can't really like
take her off her prepared script they
give you a piece of they give Jessica
some like Turkish delight and some grape
juice uh there's a big big board where
it explains the history of the family
tree of man through the names of the
Bible and the pointing to stuff none of
it makes sense it's fantastic
um go check it out the Holy Land
exhibition and the guy of course was
friends and this will Delight nick uh
with Amy simple McPherson great Amer
American and Los Angelino back in the
day who's uh Angelus Temple was just
down the street so um did enjoy it while
it still lasts I can't imagine be
interested to see like how much all that
stuff is collectively Worth or what uh
actual museums think about it but it's a
really great wonderful way to spend 90
minutes to two hours okay uh speaking of
spending 90 minutes uh with people
that's about how long this thing is
almost gone so thank you for listening
to The Reason Roundtable check out all
of our podcasts reason.com podcasts Nick
Gillespie what do we have in the future
in terms of speaking easy in the city of
New York in our March event was canceled
but in early April we'll be talking with
uh John tomasi and Matt swilinski about
their fantastic book which is a history
an intellectual history of the
libertarian movement uh called the
individualist radicals reactionaries and
the struggle for the soul of
libertarianism go to reason.com events
for information about that and other
events uh in New York and elsewhere
awesome uh and if you like what we do at
this institution please consider a tax
deductible donations but a reason to
come slash donate for more information
thank you to everyone for listening
thank you Emma Camp well done young Camp
uh and we should be welcoming Peter
suderman back next week although without
segment times goodbye
[Music]
yourself